on Prime crime that was a slick move man
very slick man go put your
hands an officer's arrests come into
question at this point you are detained
okay I don't do anything I don't mess
with he essentially was employing like
magic tricks to hide evidence We wish
you a Merry Christmas we wish you Merry
Christmas what we got there my friend
look at there but proving a crime was
committed by a member of law enforcement
is not an easy task we don't actually
ever see him planting their narcotics
that raises some red flags to me he gave
me a piece of advice sometimes the
people you think you can trust are the
very ones you shouldn't that has stuck
with me as the most chilling thing he
[Music]
said
hey everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down some of the most compelling
and memorable True Crime cases law
enforcement are supposed to be the good
guys and many times if not most of the
time they are however there is something
very odd that happens in one Florida
county and a spotlight is put on an
officer who may not actually be
arresting people for crimes but
committing them
himself look man you seem like you're
pretty squared away okay yeah yeah all
right but I do have an issue with
something within the vehicle what's that
it's April 8th 2018 in Jackson County
Florida what should have been a typical
day for a motorist suddenly becomes a
lifechanging encounter with sheriff's
deputy Zachary Wester the day I got
stopped I was actually on my way to work
I was coming through a small town there
was a police officer sitting underneath
the overpass and when he pulled in
behind me I still really didn't think
anything of it until the lights came on
and that was when I was like this is
really weird pulled you over your
driver's license is not valid okay
pulled you out to talk to you B he said
that my license had been suspended and
he realized that when he ran my plate I
was like that's strange because you were
facing me under the overpass and you
followed me for 3 miles before you flick
the lights on so the red flags were
already going up you made the
spontaneous statement about there was a
handgun in the center console he said it
was okay for me to go retrieve that
handgun from the center console yes he
asked if there was anything in the
vehicle that I thought he should be
concerned about and I was honest with
him I told him I've got a handgun in the
center console and he asked me if I had
a concealed weapons permit I said no you
don't need one in Florida at that point
he had probable cause to pull that car
over keep in mind a lot of times the
reason I pull you over does lead into
further investigation based on what I
see or maybe information that I gather
during that traffic stop all right I'm
going to read you your rights just
because I read your rights does not mean
you're going to jail okay okay you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say can be used against you in court I
knew I didn't have anything to hide
that's why I let him search my vehicle I
trusted the process
well those feelings changed a little bit
when he read me the Miranda Rights
opened up the center console shoved down
in between the front passenger seat and
where the center console is at I saw
what appeared to be a syringe sticking
out whenever I went I looked further
pulled the seat apart the syringe is
actually in like a plastic larger baggie
with a plastic container with a
substance in it that appears to be an
illegal
narcotic do you know anything about that
I do not I was shocked and I had no idea
what the heck he was talking about
because I am not a meth user I don't do
drugs I've never smoked pot I've
physically never done drugs in my life
it blew my mind that he was in here
questioning me about this you've never
seen this before dude I have no idea
it's just wild I was so surprised that
it was methamphetamines of all things it
wasn't weed it wasn't like a crack pipe
it was methamphetamines it was a used
needle track marks no dude I don't use I
mean you where we're at you got we're
standing here this definitely has the
appearance of illegal activity you're
swearing you know nothing about it it
just puts me in a bad spot man you know
I thought there had to be an explanation
maybe somebody left it in my car I don't
know I have employees maybe that's a
possibility but I know the people I hire
we do background checks I simply don't
have addicts working for me I'm not
saying you're a bad person okay yeah you
don't appear to be a user okay and if
you are a user you not been using it
long are you understand where I'm coming
from right dude I'm going to be honest
with you I go to work I come home I
sleep I go back to work I don't Pang
party I don't the the state in trust me
to be a FactFinder right try to put all
the pieces to the puzzle together if I
had a dollar for every time someone told
me these aren't my pants though you have
them on and we find the drugs in them
I'd be a very wealthy man there's that
initial denial phase I just want you to
understand where I'm coming from man
when it's say felony I have no
discretion in the State of Florida for
that okay I can't just throw that in the
ditch out here and out like it never
happened yeah um so you're going to go
to jail today for possession of
methamphetamine for possession of drug
paraphilia he took me to jail my dad
worked at the federal prison there and I
I grew up around his Lieutenant my mom
made the phone call to him and she said
hey something's wrong Joshua just got
arrested for methamphetamine possession
he went in and he signed a paper for
conditional release and he even
questioned me he grilled me pretty hard
is there something I don't know are you
making me look like an idiot and I was
honest with him and said no I was
treated like a criminal through the
whole thing it was the worst two years
of my life Joshua Emanuel is adamant
he's innocent is he telling the truth is
something else going on here little did
he know at the time he would not be the
only person claiming the same thing
after being pulled over by Deputy Wester
I've got to test this have you ever seen
this before
no no what is that it did fi test presum
the positive for methan fet ofine okay
let me ask you this yeah if I read you
your RS will you talk to me I talk to
you I'm just saying man hey dude we're
going to get there we're going to get
there okay these drug crimes are serious
um these were possession charges of
methamphetamine which can carry years in
jail if people have other prior offenses
the penalty can be even more extreme
you're going to jail you are being
legally contains this time okay back no
I
a those y going to jail okay for
possession methampetamine y'all are both
in construed possession it there's also
collateral consequences people lose
their job lose their standing in the
community custody of their children
Trust of their loved ones people who
have taken a different path in life and
have become sober now people believe
that they've been lying you didn't have
any weapons or anything you was trying
to hide back there no CU you can't even
see me man I can get invasive I'm assume
you all know way here in just minute he
didn't have
anything that was a slick move man very
slick hey man man go and put your
hands man what you
talk what are you doing man at first
glance these stops appear to be somewhat
routine and by the book during my career
I saw drugs hidden in a numerous places
a seasoned officer is going to do their
due diligence to search every inch of
that vehicle many times people who are
drug users if they get stopped and they
have the drugs they're in that panic
mode so they're just going to slide it
between the seats they're going to try
to hide it really quick so it doesn't
surprise me that some of this legal
drugs were found like in a crack of a
seat that doesn't really raise any
suspicions to me hey what' you find huh
what'd you find where in that in that
flashlight whenever I opened it up there
was some crystals on top I was
like when I W up it was shoved in
between this back seat right here and
this back she was making a lot of
movements just saying that her knees
were hurting imagine that but is
everything really as it appears to be
upon a closer review there's something
off with Wester arrests there was
troubling behavior that the officer
exhibited such as going back and forth
between his vehicle and the recovery
vehicle every time that this Contraband
was recovered there was a appeared
intentional deflection of the body cam
to not be looking in the direction of
the recovered item and so it looked that
all of a sudden these Contraband were
found within this vehicle in places
where if they were there originally they
number one could not have been seen by
the naked eye of the officer or number
two would have been known to have
existed by other vehicle
[Music]
occupants you see that white piece of
Bott right there yeah it would shift it
further over this way whenever I first
made contact you could see his shoulder
raising it was actually visibly moving
up that piece of vinal when I walked up
here and made contact with her I said
man what you doing under that vinyl he
didn't know Trevor was standing right
there he was just a digging under that
baseball club and then search that
immediate area for weapons and there a
basball glove and there was the back in
the straw you going to jail buddy going
to
jail I didn't do anything why am I going
we lock what is going on here exactly is
Deputy Wester finding drugs
or planting them up next we take a
further look at these body cam videos
there's a lot of discrepancies between
the reports and the body cam footage
these body warn cameras were either
turned on late they malfunctioned or the
video is actually deleted off of the
[Music]
server look man you going to go to jail
today for possession of methan aamine
okay it was in your vehicle right there
at center console come on man I don't
have much discretion with the fety
charge buddy I don't have much
discretion with that man
dude oh man dude I'm serious dude
anything what you want me to do man
between 2016 and 2018 Jackson County
Florida sheriff's deputy Zachary Wester
is making arrests for drug possession I
mov the driver seat forward that little
black container you saw me pull out it
had a crystallized substance in it
whenever I tested that it did return a
presumptive positive for methamphetamine
here in the field that's her you are
going to jail tonight for possession of
methamphetamine and possession of drug
paraphernalia but something is strange
in West's arrests the problem in Zachary
West's case is we have a repeated
pattern of Zachary Wester either turning
off his camera not turning it on videos
being deleted that raises red flags to
anybody is it possible that Wester could
be planting drugs on innocent people he
found it in the driver side compartment
he watch seats so when you watch these
body Cam footages most of these searches
are only being conducted by Zachary
Wester there's not a second person in
the car helping him so he's in there by
himself while the Second Officer the
backup officer is watching the suspect
so that does give Zachary Wester ample
opportunity and time to plant those
drugs
if this test what I think it's going to
test for is going to put me even more of
a bad spot because this a felony yeah
that's what I'm worried about here too
it did test presump the positive in the
field for methamphetamine the how he
planted it in my car is still a question
that literally keeps me up at night I
still can't figure it out I know what
happened I just don't know how how Qui
can you get there cuz I'm being arrested
for possession of Narcotics I don't want
to talk about it right now the only
explanation I've been able to come up
with is he went to the back of his car
he put the bag with the syringe in his
glove carried the gloves to the car
dumped it in the passenger seat then put
the gloves on and quote unquote started
his
search Jackson County police officers
they were short sleeves they weren't
long sleeves he couldn't have tucked it
in his shirt he didn't like reach down
on his boot or anything like that I
think he just carried it in his glove
from the back of his patrol car into
mine let's take a closer look at these
stops to see if Wester is the one
breaking the law you know what that is
Sir you don't know what that maybe
appears to
be
orain never seen that in my
life has some R it okay most people will
make denials and that's why the law is
pretty clear when you try to refute the
exist existence of probable cause a
suspect's denials are not sufficient to
refute probable cause oh right both of
y'all are just going to be detained at
this time okay I can undet you I just
can't unrest you what the hell but there
is a consistent look of surprise on
these people's faces you can tell when
people Fain surprise you can tell when
it's an a shuck you found my stuff this
was a little bit different fingerprints
on that bottom will I do not do drugs it
was a level of indignation shock at this
point you are detained okay all right
when I was searching the vehicle on the
side that you were seated in like a
brown tie up bag that white little
exedran bottle yeah okay bottom corner
with the way it was positioned I opened
it up there is a crystallized substance
in the bottom of it it did return a
presumptive positive for methamphetamine
here on the side out of the room so my
question is understand I don't do
anything I don't mess with that part of
the other problem is that this officer
was trying to convince them that maybe
somebody else left something in their
vehicle to explain away why they
genuinely might not know that there was
Contraband in their vehicle and so that
is able to create some plausible
deniability for him that maybe it wasn't
him that put it there you got to be
careful who you let in your vehicle okay
if that is not yours this company policy
though man I don't know what I'm going
to do about that like I have to have an
employee with me come to the bank for
the deposit every single morning West's
demeanor on the side of the road was
probably the worst part not because he
was mean but because he was so nice this
is unfortunate for you today okay just
believe me this is going to be a fork in
the road man you can go left or right
right the Buddy Buddy demeanor then oh
no you're going to jail it was a lot of
the same Mo over and over over and over
again he was playing a game which is
sick but catching Wester in the ACT is
not so
simple that black container it was right
right I combed through these videos and
you do not directly see him planting
evidence you see what could be argued to
be an inadvertent aversion of body
camera at the critical moment this stuff
is recovered he essentially was
employing like magic tricks to hide
evidence coming up can the truth be
uncovered no sir I'm not going to ask
you any questions I'm going to read to
your right first okay so just hang out
50 what is it when you are corrupt when
you are dirty when you're a liar it's
going to catch up with you at some point
but that one piece of evidence right
there proves to be crucial in this
case
[Music]
if I was driving that vehicle right
there okay and if my corpal pulled me
over and searched the vehicle and if he
found that what would happen probably
would be working in wouldn't be working
here I'd lose my certification I'd go to
jail whenever you get behind the wheel
of that vehicle dude you are in
possession of everything in this vehicle
okay out in Jackson County Florida
between 2016 and 2018 Sheriff's deput
Zachary Wester is arresting various
people after supposedly finding
narcotics in the cars they were driving
if I would have never lifted the center
console I would not have seen that
orange part sticking up it was right
between the console and the front
passenger seat man not only do these
motorist claim the drugs don't belong to
them you are in constructive possession
of methamphetamine okay so you are going
to jail today for possession of
methamphetamine because it was on your
side of the vehicle I don't do nothing
what I'm going to do though since that
young little boy looking back I'm not
going to put you in handcuffs okay but
between inconsistencies and his
reporting the body cam turning off at
Key moments and the locations of where
the drugs are found something's not
right and someone starts taking notice
there was a whistleblower in this case
named Christina Pumphrey she worked for
the state attorney's office at the time
there were a lot of things with this
case that just didn't sit right with her
so she started doing her own
investigating
We wish you a Merry Christmas we wish
you a Merry Christmas is that seat slide
man I'm in the Christmas spirit what we
got there my friend look at there they
actually start picking up on some
discrepancies from his reports to what's
actually shown on the body worn camera
and this right here is the crucial
moment we need to look into this a
little bit further we've got to notify
the supervision to start running an
investigation into Wester at that point
they start pulling all these traffic
stops however there's a big
problem so this ain't yours in the door
right
here going to be detained now okay
because the door okay I'm I'm just
detaining you just put your hands behind
your back for me on his body cam footage
we don't actually ever see him planting
their narcotics that raises some red
flags to me did he actually find the
drugs or where were they actually
planted I don't
[Applause]
know he had mastered what he was doing
he knew when to turn his body camera off
he knew when to keep it on he knew when
to find whatever he was going to find
the fact that he was so comfortable
doing it he was so good at only showing
what he wanted to show until it came to
the Teresa Odum video that's when he
really slipped upy West jck Sheriff's
Office reason for my stop is um your
brake lights they work one minute and
the next minute they don't work you got
your driver's license on you ma'am I
just got tickets the other day I'll be
glad to show no you're fine would you
consent to a search of your vehicle
you're fine with that okay you know we
saw in the Teresa Odum case where there
was a frame by frame shot of his body
camera and we saw that there was a clear
baggie in Wester hand during the
stop oh
running you can physically see a packet
with a white powder in his hand before
he puts his glove
on which he later finds that same packet
in Teresa odm's truck it is yogurt sir I
know okay it's yogurt how about this
that is not mine no sir okay I'm not g
to ask you any I'm Not Gon to ask you
any questions I'm gonna read you your
rights first okay that's what blew the
case wide open in reality what you see
in his hand before he ever searches the
truck that's what really really got him
in
trouble authorities discover a stash of
drugs and paraphernalia hidden in the
trunk of Wester patrol car after an
investigation by the Florida Department
of Law Enforcement it's suspected that
Zachary Wester planted narcotics in
dozens of traffic stops in 2019 Wester
is arrested and he's ultimately charged
with 67 crimes with respect to 12
victims racketeering official misconduct
fabricating evidence false imprisonment
perjury and possession of controlled
substances and drug
paraphernalia the first thing that I
thought was this Deputy wants to get
involved in some type of narcotics unit
so he's trying to to pad his numbers
what we kept seeing during these traffic
stops was it seemed to always be
methamphetamine nothing really surprises
me there you know we still have a
methamphetamine problem across the
United States a proactive law
enforcement officer you stumble upon
drugs on a frequent basis he's trying to
show that he goes out here he makes big
cases I worked in a unit that focused on
street level narcotics and it's hard to
get into these units he gave me a piece
of advice sometimes the people you think
you can trust are the very ones you
shouldn't that has stuck with me as the
most chilling thing he said yeah I
probably shouldn't have trusted the
police officer standing in front of me
and how awful is that to have to say
when you think of all the other people
before me and after me who he played the
same game with and he won those he had
no fear in what he was doing to have
that kind of power and use it that way
it's
disgusting Zachary Wester may have been
arrested but he is Presumed Innocent the
more challenging issue now is can
prosecutors prove Zachary Wester is
guilty I am surprised and alternately
impressed that the DA's office actually
took this to trial because I think that
everybody in law enforcement in the DA's
office they knew at the pit of their
stomach that there was something really
wrong here but convincing people who are
not in the industry a jury of just
regular folks that this was a deviation
and a criminal act was actually a heavy
[Music]
lift that man singing it we wish you a
Merry Christmas we wish you a merry
Christmas and I like the hum a tune in
case something ever goes in front of a
jury you know so so they're not just
sitting somewhere just like elev
not just sitting somewhere chilling
hanging out in May 2021 a Florida trial
began that was quite startling to see a
former police officer named Zachary
Wester was facing 67 criminal charges in
connection with planting drugs on
unsuspecting and innocent
motorists this is a case about an abuse
of an incredible power the defendant
used his position as a deputy sheriff to
make traffic stops on 12 members of this
community implant methampetamine in
their cars methamphetamine and
paraphernalia he turned what should be a
law enforcement agency and is and is
something for his own
use that was criminal the strongest
evidence was what was examined under a
closer Professional Eye we have a very
similar Mo a policy a practice that this
individual employed the recovery of the
same type of substance not within direct
view of body cam movements that could
not be accounted for Divergent paperwork
unexplained discrepancies in tests and
field
testing Josh Emanuel voluntarily told
the defendant that he had a gun in his
car before the defendant had any reason
to search it now why would he do that if
methamphetamine was really in his car
why would Mr Bing give the defendant
Corrections ID letting this stany know
right away that he's got a criminal
history why would he do that if there
was methamphetamine in the car if I know
that was in there you think i' tell you
goe and search man come on man really
people still do sometimes why would they
consent to a search the car there's no
reason to they consented the
search cuz they didn't have anything to
hide and the prosecution honed in on
arguably their strongest piece of
evidence why in the world does the
defendant have palmed in his hand which
is clasped like this not like this not
like this like this a plastic baggie why
in the world does he have that there I
would submit that this is objective
evidence where you see him planting
drugs in the moment you see something in
his hand that has no reason no logical
reason given this stop and what we know
about it for it to be there this is him
planting evidence and you see it people
were saying you could see the baggie I I
could not see it I think the hardest
part for prosecutor here is number one
there's no smoking on and number two
there's a really flimsy motive for the
regular person you have to understand
why someone with so much to lose would
risk Mr Wester went one by one through
each and every stop and
arrest many other officers all nothing
unusual no red flags with anything Mr
Wester did many of those same officers
were not surprised at all that those
suspects denied ownership of the drugs
in the paraphernalia that Mr Wester
found in their cars there is no direct
evidence of Mr Wester doing anything
wrong not one person said they saw him
doing anything unusual not actually
seeing him plant the drugs that may come
off as ah you know that was just a bad
angle of the camera but again ju jurries
do want to actually see that jurors want
to see physical evidence many of them
entered pleas nobody challenged anything
in a courtroom and nobody filed any
complaints with the Sheriff's Office
here's the other harder part the victims
some of them pleaded guilty and what
that means is if you plead guilty you
can't later say that you didn't do it
the people who admitted that the drugs
were theirs in the eye of the law the
drugs were theirs most of the people
that got up there in touch testified
also said yeah I'm suing at least one of
them said yes a conviction here would
definitely help my civil
case so is there an interest yes and
what is that money some of these people
on traffic stops entered a a guilty plea
because they felt like who's going to
believe my word over a deputy sheriff's
word that's a legitimate concern so
you've got a public defender or your
attorney that's saying hey look if you
just plead to this you're going to get
no prison time the pressure is on you
just to say I want this go away and the
jury got to hear from those alleged
victims
themselves the white small plastic
baggie that was in that spoon that the
deputy just showed you on this video had
you ever seen that before yes sir was
that in your car no sir he said that he
smelled marijuana emitting from the
vehicle had you been smoking marijuana
in the vehicle no sir absolutely not
what about Miss Smith absolutely not she
was 3 months pregnant how long was was
it between you packing Regal's lunch and
this defendant pulling you over and
saying he found meth in it uh less than
5 minutes was there any meth in that
lunch box no sir did you put any math in
no sir he told Orin put his hands behind
his back and he told me to go over
towards the tree at some point did you
try to film this on your phone yes sir
what happened he was acting weird he
told me that I would be a r if I did not
put my phone down testifying against
Wester was is Scary Just for the fact
that you're testifying against a law
enforcement officer the only thing I
really have saw was the fact that he did
kept going back into the car like
several times over and over and over
again cuz he'd come back he' talk to me
he'd go back to the car he'd come back
to me he'd go back to the car this is
someone the state has put in place to
protect and serve they're entrusted with
the public safety they're entrusted to
do the right thing and they took an oath
to do so so when you're sitting in a
courtroom saying that's a dirty cop it
doesn't look good he said he found a
syringe in a baggie that looked like it
had been used he said it was uh stuffed
down in between the passenger seat and
the Senter console would you have seen
it if something was there oh for sure
yeah was there anything like that there
no everybody says they're innocent
everybody said it wasn't mine you know
everybody says they have nothing to do
with it so going into that you're
thinking how many other people have been
in my spot testifying against an officer
typically that doesn't go very well you
never saw with a needle or bag or
anything in his hands until after he
came out of your car no he was pretty
far in there when he was reaching for
the gun did you see him reaching in his
pockets or anything
no and he's wearing short sleeves so he
didn't have anything up his sleeves
either did
he but I knew I had to do it I had a
clean record I was the quote unquote key
witness in this case because of my clean
record so me testifying was a big deal
for the state then it was time for
Zachary Wester to take the stand did you
plant this substance in Mr Williams's
lunchbox I did not the report that you
wrote in that case did you falsify
anything in this report nothing no sir
with Miss Wood was there anything with
her that you planted so that you could
arrest her no was there anything in your
report that wasn't true about Miss Wood
no the marijuana shake and the
methampetamine that you found in the
vehicle did you plant that there I did
not no this case is tough because you're
dealing with a professional witness cops
part of their job is they testify police
officers are trained to be great
Witnesses the allegation is you found
six but only entered five into evidence
and that would be correct okay tell us
why it was determined that one that was
unused could have very well been for his
diabetes that he just stated that he
uses syringes for um so I didn't
determine that one to be of evidentiary
value and it was just simply disposed of
did you take that other needle and hide
it in your car to plant in somebody
else's car later no I did not there are
certain strategies and techniques when
people testify that become learned and
practiced over time not getting overly
emotional answering only what is asked
responding in a way that is
non-confrontational non-argumentative in
all of these cases that we've talked
about you did not plant any evidence
that never crossed my mind no these were
legitimate stops searches and you found
illegal narcotics yes sir by and large
he was really good on the stand
methamphetamine is quite prevalent here
in Jackson County correct
methamphetamine is very prevalent in
Jackson County I've seen firsthand the
destruction that methamphetamine has on
families um has on friends and in my job
as a deputy sheriff I wanted to be as
proactive as I could I didn't feel that
the citizens of Jackson County wanted to
pay me to just sit somewhere and wait
for a call Wester even tried to explain
way the arguably incriminating evidence
from the Odum stop in the void space
there was a baggy of some sort I didn't
know at the time if it was of
evidentiary value or not it didn't
appear as if it had narcotics in it it
didn't appear as if it had anything that
may have been of value but nonetheless I
wanted to try to preserve it so I
grabbed it and whenever I entered the
vehicle it was in my left hand but I
wanted to be able to still use my
fingers before I put my gloves on I
moved my hand and I place that item in
the driver's side floorboard and I
continued my search the state was
showing these still photos there's
something in your hand sure there is
something in your hand
absolutely was it that bag of
methamphetamine that's sitting there on
that spoon right now it was not no it
was obvious to me that Wester had been
coached a lot for his testimony that's
not uncommon Wester had done his
homework work and really prepped for the
questions that were probably going to be
asked by the state prosecution where on
your body camera video do we see you
handle that baggie and and either
picking it up or putting it down or
looking at it closely to determine
what's in it whenever I put that baggie
in the front driver side
floorboard I never seen it again I'm not
sure if it's because when a semi came
through it blew it into the roadway
there was really no need for me to go
walk AC across 231 at the busiest time
of the day to try to find something that
I didn't even know was evidentiary value
or not why' you set it down on the
floorboard if you didn't know if it had
evidentiary value or not so that I could
search the vehicle how about searching
what's in your hand how about that I
didn't expect him to actually get on the
stand he kept like moving his nose he
was very Twitchy and nervous the whole
time he lost his cool on the stand
several times with State Attorney your
theory was that because mom had been in
the car at some point and Mom had been a
meth user years
before that even if they were an
accidental possession that you went
ahead and arrested them I did and here's
the thing most of the time they deny
knowledge so Mr Williams you're you're
presenting to this jury that in the
first circuit where you work that if
someone says that they didn't know about
the narcotics you're just going to drop
the case on every single narcotics
charge that comes on your desk
you know that's not what I'm saying it
sounds to me that's what you're saying
okay well thank you for your input I'll
remind you as you're aware that I ask
the questions and you answer them sure I
just really believe that he came across
a little cocky a little arrogant versus
hey I'm truly innocent here the goal of
the body camera is to allow someone else
in this very court system perhaps to see
what you or any other Deputy would see
while they had that body camera on is't
that right body cameras are very
beneficial yes not for Reginal Williams
we don't have one right so why don't we
have one for him if the body camera
video for Mr Reginald Williams would not
have been deleted from the server this
jury would have had a chance to review
that body camera who deleted it Mr
Willams I don't know if someone deleted
it did they delete the front part of the
manual video did they go in and delete
that as well Mr Willams I've already
testified as to the first part of that
Emanual video and I made it very clear
that the body camera experienced a
malfunction and it so happened that that
missed the part where you would have
first gotten into the car and had a
chance to see the syringe in the bagy is
that right I would disagree with that
that's not when the err occurred I would
disagree with that then why isn't it on
the video Mr Williams I've explained
this to you three or four times now as
far as why that is not on the video is
there some reason you will not answer
that to the
jury the body camera error occurred as
soon as the traffic stop was initiated
the defense's case was actually pretty
solid and it's not really due to the
defense attorney it was Wester covering
of his actions he had an explanation for
everything he had cut his body cam on
and off at certain times perfectly and
explained it away as a malfunction you
know and they questioned people involved
in it in that department you know is
this a possibility well yeah it's a
possibility it's a body cam now you
testified that you saw Kimberly
Hazelwood reach down and put that
Excedrin bottle in that trash bag is
that right yes where's that on the video
the body camera doesn't pick it up okay
but whenever you look through the back
window you will be surprised at how a
body camera how it darkens things and
you have to remember a body camera sees
a narrow field of view it sees what it
wants to see so I was able to see that
with my eyes through that back class
that was tough to sit in the courtroom
and say I don't know how he did it but I
know he
did and I hope there's enough evidence
to prove it the packet being in his hand
before he put his glove on the fact that
he didn't have him finding anything on
camera it was just there so the jury
really had to go by their belief in
whether or not he was a dirty cop and to
the jury this case went would they
believe Zachary Wester was upholding the
law or breaking the law after
deliberating more than 7 hours over the
course of 2 days this was the jury's
decision we the jury find as follows as
to the Count's charge and the
information count one guilty of
racketeering as charged count two not
guilty count three not guilty count four
not
guilty count seven guilty of official
misconduct related to Teresa odm as
charged in a split decision the jurors
found Zachary Wester guilty of 19
charges including racketeering official
misconduct false imprisonment and
possession but not guilty on 48 other
charges so I think they came back with
the right verdict convicting him on the
charges that they had the strongest
evidence on
there were so many more not- guilties
called out than there were guilty
verdicts and that was rough to hear as
someone who went through it he's getting
off on all of these cases but in the end
after all was said and done he was found
guilty on charges relating to three of
the people involved myself Steven Van
and Teresa Odum in that moment you're
like someone realized that this wasn't
right and you start thinking that maybe
he'll get the time he
[Music]
deserves as to count one racketeering
which is a first-degree felony you are
sentenced to serve five years in the
Florida Department of
Corrections asked to count seven
official misconduct 18 months as to
count 31 fabricating evidence one year
and one day asked to count 64 that's
false imprisonment you were sentenced to
serve one one year and one day therefore
it is the intention of the court that
you are sentenced to serve a total of 12
Years 6 months in 8 days in the Florida
Department of Corrections there's no one
that dislikes a dirty cop more than I do
it's wrong it's taints the agency it
taints the badge actions and behavior
like this in law enforcement will not be
tolerated and you will be held
accountable for your actions people lost
kids
grandkids their right to work no
questions asked I mean I still have my
fair share of side effects from it to
this day if I see police
lights I my heart drops and I have a
panic attack on the road there's a bad
apple in every profession but when you
run into a bad cop that can change your
life and it can be for the good it can
be for the worst in this time for a lot
of people it was for the worst
for a moment just think about the impact
that Zachary Wester had here so in total
prosecutors dropped charges in
119 cases involving Wester over 30 of
the people that he arrested agreed to a
nearly 1 million federal court
settlement his career reputation ruined
he's locked up behind bars for years and
you have all of these people who are
going to go through life knowing that
they were falsely arrested by someone
who was entrusted to a hold the law and
all of this for what that question of
why he did it it is still not clear and
honestly I'll tell you what it may never
be
clear that's all we have for you here on
this episode of prime crime everybody
thank you so much for joining us we're
going to see you next time and as always
stay
safe
[Music]